what were you doing before you were
doing supplements
like for business yeah yeah prior to
that we had a vertically integrated
Dental operation so uh so what I really
mean by that is um you got you guys
might know that my wife is a retired
dentist and um retired shouts to
ancestral living yeah there you go and
so she had uh every discipline of
Dentistry worked underneath her so if
you needed anything related to Dentistry
we had the oral surgeon the periodontist
or You Name It We had the Imaging Center
that was there we had a lab that was
there so it was it was a pretty big
operation that we had going on and we
did that for a long time we had that for
I don't know maybe maybe 10 to 15 years
and one day she said I'm done
because I'm done and she's like it's on
you it's the best thing that could have
happened you know is for her to say this
is on you now yeah I wasn't very
ancestral living off your wife's money
that's right that's right not that
Primal whoa that's awesome oh you're 100
right I mean think about it that's not
ancestral at all for her yeah to be
providing you know like what she needed
to do was this is breaking news this is
great and and you know caretake
compassion making sure you're wearing a
shirt and [ __ ] like yeah that was
possible
so were you stay-at-home Dad no no no no
no no no no
so really we're just walking around the
surgery center all buff knocking [ __ ]
over like what are we doing yeah pretty
much that
that's about right that was [ __ ] [ __ ]
up pretty bad
so uh when we met uh I was in device
sales she was a dentist she and then she
came to Houston she started doing
Dentistry for other office because I
hate this and I don't want to work for
other people I was like okay let's go do
this thing so we started this thing we
bought a practice uh and we were like oh
my God we're pretty [ __ ] good at this
and so we just we built it and we grew
it and instead of referring all of these
patients outside to other Specialists we
brought them all inside and so we did
this for a while and it worked out
financially we struggled also during the
time because we overbought the building
that we were in uh but long story short
you know like uh
that starts to go downhill pretty fast
and uh and so then I quit my other job
to come in and to to fix this so she
focused on dentistry and I focused on
the business and [ __ ] [ __ ] up pretty
bad yeah um you know the building that
we have there's also a surgery center
you know with some uh surgeons that were
and so talk about [ __ ] [ __ ] up around
surgery centers yeah yeah they don't
make them for big guys yeah and your
supplements are always ancestral in
nature or if you said 2014 you've always
been doing this kind of thing yeah you
know actually when she said okay I'm
done I said okay well you know what am I
going to do to figure this out and so
the first product I had is called tooth
restore this was my idea thank God it
didn't come to Market it is coming to
Market
um but but the root cause of most oral
issues have to do with our nourishment
and mechanical loading right and so most
people aren't eating liver they're not
getting bone marrow they're not getting
what they need from egg yolk or the Sun
and so how do we get that [ __ ] in a
capsule and as she starts talking to
people about the nourishment hey here's
what you need to be eating here's how
you address the root cause I don't want
to see you again right here's you you're
fixing them you're fixing them so they
don't need to come back to the dentist
well this is what she's trying to do and
you know what people are patients are
saying just fix my teeth yeah yeah just
fix my teeth do you think you're gonna
talk to me about nutrition just fix my
teeth yeah and then there's a small
percent of patients are like okay but
you know what I can't eat liver I I
tried it in my mouth yeah yeah I don't
want to do that either yeah yeah you
know um actually we we had a a lot we
were in a gay community so a lot of them
all right
so what ends up happening it's like okay
I got this idea let's do this and and
then I realized you know what this is
way bigger than this yeah this is way
bigger than this we're not going to do
this just related just targeted to the
dental community and so that kind of
took off from there so she got you into
ancestral living
you know what got me intense with living
is my boys couldn't breathe right it was
that yes and we cut out all the
processed food that's not mostly what's
he laughing
you did what your wife told you
we're all married
your wife tells you to do some [ __ ] you
do it okay we know what's up liver kick
that's the real liver
Queens on couches and chairs
that's why we're still goddamn alive I
love you babe I [ __ ] love you okay
now this is beautiful I'm glad you came
on here
um you know I think that all too often
you you know you see this in comedy you
see this in pretty much you know every
industry people get written off for a
mistake that they made and you know one
of the things that I think that we like
to stand on over here is that we're not
part of the whole you know I guess you
could say uh cancel culture uh umbrella
now you did something where you [ __ ]
up you admitted you [ __ ] up we learned
more about you as a person and uh your
motives for not only building your brand
but also like building out this Flagship
ancestral living ideology that you've
been sharing at learning that I think
that's really cool I think I understand
you as a man a lot more I'm gonna call
you Brian because I know you as Brian
and I think that you're a fully formed
person as Brian so that makes that that
means a lot to me that you came on thank
you for sharing your story brother and
uh I hope you enjoyed yourself best of
luck with everything in the future thank
you guys I appreciate it thank you bro
thank you anything you want to tell the
people before we leave
eat liver because liver is King fair
enough
donut donut donut
come on